[Music]
linda joins us up next in charlotte
north carolina linda welcome to the show
thank you
absolutely how can we help
um i'm on baby step seven and i am
retired
and i want to know what the market the
way it is right now what is the best way
to invest a hundred thousand to a
hundred and fifty thousand
um i've talked with the smart pro um a
smart investor pro and
they kind of want to assume all of my
portfolio which is a little over a
million dollars and they charge ten
thousand dollars a year to do that about
one percent one and a quarter percent
and i was just wondering um
with the smart thing way to invest and
that would be
yeah well first of all congrats baby
step seven you got a paid for house
you're retired how's retirement going
very good thank you good well i can tell
it's very relaxing when you have money
so this is a good problem to have so you
got you got about a hundred thousand to
invest and you're wondering what the
right way to do it and you contacted a
smart investor pro and what you're
talking about is assets under management
so they charge a yearly fee
uh in order to do that and one percent
is kind of the industry standard
and you're saying hey should i be giving
the 10 000 to the smarvester pro or is
there something i should be doing on my
own
yes um another investor that i have most
of my portfolio with from
years ago
recommended getting a three-year bank cd
that pays arena quarter three and a half
percent
how old are you linda i know
i am 67 67 okay
i at your age i would not no i would not
i would not put this money in a cd i i
mean okay still at your age i agree
you're i mean you still
i mean
god willing i'm like you could still
have 20 years left linda right 20 maybe
even 30 years even 30 years
um so that's still a significant i mean
that's that's two three decades that you
possibly could still have so
um that you could be in the market so if
i were you
um i trust our smart investor pros i
mean that we we vet them and we
we really do they they do the ramsey way
and if they don't we have people call us
let us know but but they really do what
we teach and i think because of your age
i think even if you just got in a mutual
fund and still even though it's kind of
crazy right now because of the market
when you actually have money though and
you have your set up so well
really the way to look at it is that
things are on sale right now you can
actually be buying a whole lot more
because i think the market will recover
uh we believe in the american economy
enough to know that it will recover
um out of this and
and yeah if i were you i would i would
put money in the market i'd put that
hundred grand and unless there's
something else that you're wanting to do
with it i don't know if even real estate
if you you know if there's something
else you don't wanna you wanna do but at
this point you may not even wanna mess
with anything
and putting it and parking it somewhere
and even just living off that interest
yeah do you need this income linda
no i don't okay so this is like bonus
fund money right now but you just want
to stew it at once it is
and it's okay um i guess i have trouble
trusting someone that i just met yeah
it's okay to basically follow all their
suggestions they're probably going to
want to manage the whole portfolio which
means
moving funds over to them
well they're going to do whatever you're
comfortable with so if any any financial
advisors yeah your your job is to tell
them what to do their job is to advise
you
on what the best options are but they're
not going to do anything for you they're
going to educate you on what your best
route is and linda never that's our
advice always no matter your age and
situation never put your money in
something you do not understand so if
there's throwing terms out and you're
thinking oh god i mean i guess you don't
just blindly trust them because they are
smart investor pro or they're an
investment professional or whoever it is
you need to fully understand and ask
questions
uh before you put your money and i want
you to be completely comfortable with it
and again they're not going to just tell
you what to do they should advise you
and even give you different options and
different routes and
and the prayer is that they have a heart
of a teacher that they're there to help
you understand and know what's going on
it's not going to be this
or yeah this experience of oh gosh
here's all these terms i have no idea
and i feel intimidated and so i'm going
to just trust because george and rachel
said to do it i want you to feel
comfortable and then if you don't feel
comfortable don't do it
no we just had one initial meeting and
it was um just kind of like a
preliminary and um i did feel very
comfortable with him as soon as i met
him
and but then they're like as the days
are passing by then i i just get cold
feet sure because i just met him well
it's scary i mean you guys have worked
so hard to build this wealth and you've
done an amazing job and so you're wise
to go hey i want to make sure that hold
on to it yeah whoever i work with i
trust and so here's one thing on the fee
if this helps you
their job is to choose funds that
outperform the market
so if you look at the average over the
last 30 years you know you're looking at
10 11 12 percent and so to pay someone
one percent to get me 11 return you're
still doing real good you're still
making six figures a year
on that compound growth and so i don't
want the one percent to scare you off
from ever leaving this money in a cd or
a savings account where it can't even
keep up with inflation instead of still
making nine ten eleven percent uh you
know when the market's doing well so i
wanna encourage you that don't let the
fee scare you away
do it when you feel ready when you
understand it
okay thank you so much for the call
linda way to go